okay so let's take this screenwriter
who's arrived in town maybe they found a
networking event on Twitter eventful
something and they show up what are they
doing how are they not being too
parasitic and creepy how are they being
not too introverted what's the right
balance you know I'm gonna take this
back to an anecdote a friend of the
families of mine and my husband's is a
director and my husband's not in the
industry and this director sat down with
us for brunch one day and told my
husband how he was going in all these
generals this is director who's done a
big movie for Fox etc etc and my husband
said to him I I don't understand what do
you do you go in all these generals what
do you do what what's the point
and he said my point is to get these
people to like me and that is what
networking is all about it's to get
people to connect with you and like you
so it's not about getting to know
everybody
it's not about meeting every last person
it's not about giving your business card
to every last person but finding a few
people to connect with to exchange
experiences with to be real to be
interesting because the interesting
thing about this industry is that it's
not just an industry it's also a
lifestyle people who participate in it
participate in it oftentimes 24 hours a
day seven days a week so they want to
work and help promote and help boost
other people that they like so it is
about making those genuine connections
with people who potentially will help
you along will give you some information
potentially in the beginning the only
read your script didn't give you some
notes but then they may get repped and
then they may offer to introduce you to
their agent to their manager so it
really is about building relationship
networking I think has gotten a bum rap
it has the sticky icky feeling of you
know I have to sell myself somehow it's
not about that it's about connecting
with people it's about forging
relationships and doing it effortlessly
usually the best way to network is in
the spirit of generosity what can I do
for you what can I offer you what MIT do
I have that could be interesting to you
forget what you can do for me so finding
those relationships finding people that
you can talk to and potentially whether
you offer them and you don't have to
offer everyone - everything always but
whether there's information life
experience that you can share that will
inform something that they're writing
that will inform something they're
pretty
you saying that goes a long way so it
really is about listening a lot
inquiring a lot learning about that
other person and building those bonds so
that suddenly when that one networking
event is over that person that you just
met met emails you later that night and
says oh by the way there's another
meetup it's people don't really know
about it but if you want to come had a
great time meeting you tonight so it is
about building those bonds and building
those relationships I was talking
earlier today to a client of mine who
just sold a show a show to NBC and this
client was speaking of all the people
who've come out of the woodwork that she
hasn't talked to in 10 or 15 years who
just dropped her an email saying hey I
heard you sold the show would you staff
me oh nice and we talked about the fact
that nobody would staff somebody they
haven't talked to in 15 years or they've
only met once but they would staff or
they would at least consider somebody
they know and like so the fostering of
relationships is really what networking
is about in this industry building and
maintaining relationships with people
starts with one or two and it grows from
there it's about having five six ten
meaningful relationships as opposed to
knowing everybody in town and not having
them know you back yeah I think we've
almost lost the art of that a little bit
because it's so easy to look someone up
on social media or online just find out
what they do and then just go right in
for the pitch instead of just being
human so it sounds like just still
remaining human remembering that it's a
person they're ordering drinks or food
or whatever and you're still in this
little bar or wherever it is an event
absolutely and not instead going for the
big ask or the big pitch I prefer you
know I always tell my clients I don't
want you to ask for anything if people
like you they will offer if you ask even
if they say yes they're likely not going
to deliver because they're not invested
but if they like you they will offer all
on their own you know agents and
managers talk about it a lot what their
networking is like because they're in
breakfast lunch dinner drinks daily
nobody likes to be sold to right nobody
likes that experience if I'm just
selling you something now and then go on
to your next meeting and where you'll be
sold again so it is about remembering
the details about the other person on
the other side of the table and agents
and managers will speak to that they
will sit down they will talk for an hour
about how's the wife and how's the kids
and what are you doing and are you still
hand gliding remembering those details
and really building those relationships
then permits them at the end of that
lunch after the hour had passed to say
and by the way there's this one writer I
really want to talk to you about at that
point there's an exchange that
everybody's comfortable with because
there's enough of a foundational
relationship that allows for that to
occur what a lot of writers forget and
what a lot of people forget because of
the nervousness that networking inspires
is that your job is really to connect
it's to build relationships you don't
build relationships with an ask you
build it with a give and oftentimes you
build it from learning about the other
person rather than just informing them
about you
you